how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and as
we get closer to the end of this year
2020 where we had absolutely no
new marvel content either shows or
movies
fans are looking forward to the end of
this year so next year can get started
and we can get some official marvel
content
but before the year is over fans are
really looking forward to the spider-man
3 teaser that we were promised for those
of you who may not be aware a sony
executive promised a couple of months
ago that we would be getting our first
look at spider-man 3 in december of 2020
before the end of the year
sony hasn't said anything since so we
can assume that we are still going to
get our first look
and an official account for paramount
pictures recently posted on twitter that
sony pictures
is going to give fans a gift for
christmas a box that if you open it
all three spider-man from the 21st
century tom holland toby mcguire and
andrew garfield
will appear in the same film and
according to them it's coming on
december
25th and as i promised i'll keep
everybody updated if i hear anything
about it which leads us to today's video
we have some more information about toby
maguire in spider-man 3 and there's a
teaser trailer going around that is
supposedly leaked that we're going to
talk about as well so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest spider-man 3
and mcu videos also this week's giveaway
is a modoc from the avengers game funko
pop provided by heroeshideout.com
now of course as we all know spider-man
3 is going to be a spider-verse film
to the extent of what exactly it's going
to be we're not too sure
not sure if these characters are going
to be a cameo or if they're going to
have a major role in the film
but in reality it kind of doesn't matter
because fans just want to see tom
holland
toby maguire and andrew garfield on the
same screen which is pretty much
99 confirmed that we're going to get and
according to a new report from daniel
richmond toby maguire is just about to
sign
and sony doesn't want to show anything
until he does sign
his official tweet said i hear they want
to close things with toby before showing
us anything
they need that money shot this means
that for the teaser they actually want
to show us
all three spider-man and confirm that it
is in fact a spider-verse movie which
would be a great move by them because
everybody practically knows already that
it is a spider-verse movie we just need
to hear it from marvel and sony and the
whole entire internet would freak out if
on december 25th they showed us a
picture of all three spider-man together
and revealed the official
title which i think is going to be the
teaser that we get
now keep in mind that toby maguire has
already committed to spider-man 3 you
don't begin this movie and plan a big
spider-verse movie without getting a
commitment
they're most likely just working out
final details as far as money is
concerned which is usually the case but
again toby is most likely already
committed because you don't plan a
really big movie like this unless you've
already got all the commitments so
hopefully the teaser on december 25th if
it does indeed come on christmas day
will confirm the spider-verse and
speaking of teaser there is supposedly a
leaked spider-man 3 teaser going around
right now that i've been getting a ton
of questions about
i'll show it right now so you know what
i'm talking about and then break it down
[Applause]
[Music]
now i wish i could tell you that this is
real and it's a teaser from spider-man 3
but i doubt it i've been told that it's
from a spider-man
fan film although i haven't been able to
find the film yet but regardless i don't
think it's real because i don't think
music would be done for this scene yet
and after all it is just spider-man
in the rain getting up probably from a
battle of some sort
it's not really much of a teaser but it
still most likely isn't from spider-man
3.
this isn't something that would really
get fans super excited about the movie
again according to daniel richmond sony
wants to show
everybody aka the money shot as it's
referred to
and that's what we want as well because
everybody will lose their minds
so sadly but not so sadly i don't think
this is real but hopefully we get a real
teaser in just
a few days it's the final countdown for
predictions on what you think the
spider-man 3
title is going to be so let me know your
predictions in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
latest news for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
you